from the restoration of classical
paintings in Flanders to the hectic
crumpet festival of gucchy
or the timeless taste of Napoli pizzas
to eco-design architecture in Denmark
European cultural heritage is as broad
and diverse as its history half of
UNESCO's World Heritage Sites are
located in Europe to celebrate and
preserve such a rich background the EU
has made 2018 the European year of
cultural heritage jewel tree tree meal
and historians we are fooled on all the
know strategies piano for jazz la nostra
the otaku moon a non personal s regiment
iike throughout the year thousands of
activities are taking place across
Europe local regional national and
European levels among these initiatives
the European Parliament hosted a
conference politicians cultural workers
and artists in Brussels more than
300,000 people are directly working in
the cultural field that as many as seven
point eight million jobs were created
indirectly by the sector preserving
cultural heritage is not just an
expenditure investing one euro in
culture gives a return of more than
twenty yep I could to sell you off with
a destroyer Universal City Council a
post booster assistive affair also City
clear harsh without dammit the cost we
left me having the value of the Sony
Vaio's in it if you want to find an
event near you to celebrate European
cultural heritage head over to the
official website
[Music]